in a socially distanced european
parliament
svetlana tikenovskaya the face of the
protest movement
collects the eu's annual award for
defending human rights
we are not alone here today
beside us are thousands of belarusians
who inspire us give us
strength and hope
until a few months ago she was a teacher
with no political ambitions
but when her husband and opposition
candidate was jailed ahead of august's
presidential election
she vowed to continue his campaign
stepping up to challenge a man
often described as europe's last
dictator alexander lukashenko
who's been in power for 26 years
the european union's called the vote
neither free nor fair
president lukashenko was sworn in for a
sixth term and tikanovskaya was forced
into exile
hundreds of thousands of people began
protesting week after week
calling lukashenka's victory
illegitimate and demanding he leave
office
over the past few months you have shown
the world what it means not to give up
you have defended your rights and you
have not given up the struggle despite
the pain
the suffering and the fear belarus's
summer of discontent is extending into
the winter
protesters braving freezing temperatures
and refusing to give up
their war cry long live belarus
and they're using a new tactic to evade
the security forces
holding smaller rallies away from the
central city
gathering and dispersing sometimes
within minutes
it's been described as an underground
resistance organized in secret chats on
social media
these crowds chant i'm going out the
last words of a fellow protester
as he left his house in minsk he died
after being beaten by police
the european union sanctioned lukashenko
for what international monitors describe
as massive systemic rights abuses
but of science says more actions needed
we call europe to be braver in their
decision
and support the people of belarus now
lukashenko said he'll step down after a
new constitution is agreed
but hasn't said when opposition
protesters say
they'll stay on the streets until he's
gone alexia o'brien al jazeera